- They say all lives matter,
and I believe that for the most part,
but then I think about Black Lives Matter,
and to me that's significant.
I remember being raised
in the neighborhood
and our training ground
was the neighborhood.
And I remember back then,
I think my training started in the '80s.
That's when they had the
red and the blue thing
going on back then, and
you had to be real careful
how you navigated the streets back then.
You had to be careful
what colors you's worn,
the neighborhoods you're
ran, and stuff like that,
'cause if you were
caught in the wrong area
with the wrong color,
then you can be what
they call a statistic.
And I learned early on that
it was no joke in the trying
to navigate the concrete
jungle of my neighborhood.
And then I got some more training later on
down the road, and that was in
the form of being in prison.
So while in prison I remember being known
those level threes and level four yours,
what they had the gun towers,
and they had the barbwire,
and they had the walls,
and I had to walk a fine thin
line just to get through that.
So what was important for me,
as far as the lessons I
learned in prison was,
when you police yourself,
there's a good chance
that you would have none
of the inmates hovering over your ass,
talking to you, and checking
you on one of your mistakes.
So one of your flukes.
And another thing is
you don't have the COs
in your bed area, and causing trouble,
and all that kind of stuff.
'Cause back in the days in prison
if you had a problem with a CO,
it was a good chance that he
knew some men up in there,
and he would sick 'em on your ass,
and they will deal with you accordingly.
And I think they hurt a lot of men.
A lot of people got hurt under
those bylaws, as they say.
And I think they just
stopped doing that recently.
Now, the last time I was in prison
I was gone from 2011 to 2017.
And I think in 2015, they
stopped whooping on the men
for the COs in prisons man.
And I think that came from
level, like from the heads,
from the people in charge, man,
that's already in prison
at different ones.
Man, I think they wrote a (indistinct)
and shut that shit down the line,
and it went from level to level.
It went more from the level four,
to, I think it came all
the way from Pelican Bay,
from the big shots on the
yard, men that ran shit,
that really runs stuff behind the scenes.
And so it came from the from Pelican Bay,
to the level four, to the level threes,
two, ones, and tools, wasn't
part camps and all that.
And it said no more putting your hands
on each other for the public, for the COs
for the correctional officers.
And that didn't happen, man.
And I was in prison
at the time when that took
place men or what a relief man.
So training men is real important.
'Cause if you don't get a
choice is going to get it.
You know what I mean?
When it comes to Black
Lives Matter self-deception
and self-paid that shit burn.
It's a fine line man, on
how you look at it, man
because overall I remember
when I was growing
up and I was caught up
in that self-deception.
Now part, I heard about somebody
around the corner getting Shotters
or the police shooting
somebody down the street
across town, I'll say,
Oh man, I feel so bad.
You know, but it wouldn't penetrate it.
It was like I didn't feel the empathy.
I couldn't put myself in their shoes
in his momma's shoes or his sibling shoes
and nothing like that
I would just read about
it or hear about it on TV.
And I said, you know, it set up, you know
little Ray or Ronnie or
little Bobby, you know, bobo
you know, whoever it was at the time.
And instead of
self-deception that shit was
with me from the early beginning, man.
So as long as it didn't happen
with Lunken nothing bad didn't happen
to me or to any of my family members, Dan
always going with the flow,
just rolling with the times,
man, whatever was going on
at that time in my life and
then comes the second half
of that fight Dan line,
when it comes to real
does it really matter about black lives
or any lives in particular
hail mother fucker no
for the simple fact that said cell patriot
I couldn't see paths.
If somebody got shot or
somebody got ran over hit
and run or whatever the case may be
with that cell Patriot
thing, man, it was like, man
I don't give fuck.
I really don't.
I don't care.
It doesn't matter because
it didn't, I didn't notice
I didn't know what the Joe or Mary
or whoever it was that made
my got injured at the time.
And that's how deep that shit was.
I sit on TV and I look at it.
I read about it in a newspaper
or in a book somewhere like that.
And it wouldn't even register, man.
It wouldn't register and that's real,
no empathy, no sympathy, no nothing.
Cause I didn't care.
How can I care about somebody
else, man, when I don't care
about my damn self,
when push comes to shove
sit as self-deception and
as self-hatred man should
as the fine thin line when it comes
to any lives matter, man.
'Cause when it's all said and
done, you don't give a fuck
about nobody, nothing to
nobody, because you'll ask me
my actions showed me that I didn't care.
I didn't care about me.
I didn't give a fuck what happened to me?
I didn't care if I got shot, robbed
stabbed and all that kind of stuff, man.
It didn't matter.
Took a long time for it to matter.
Took a long time for my life to matter
for me to matter to me
going through the motions
and all that bull shit.
Every time I interact with
somebody, how you doing all that?
Everything is good.
Will be a bullshit.
Everything wasn't good,
but I couldn't admit it.
I couldn't tell you that.
Oh, did you hear about so-and-so?
Did you hear about so-and-so?
Yeah, I heard about what multiple.
Okay, and move on to the next phase.
What's the next thing on
the agenda on the link.
That's just the way it
was man for a long time,
nothing registered,
nothing penetrated me, man.
Nothing got me to see
the other person's man
or the other family's situation
and circumstances and
all that kind of stuff.
But I had the right kind of training.
I had the proper training.
No, cause they had three
different types of trainings.
You know, I had the neighborhood training,
I had the prison setting,
setting training.
And then after that I have
my own personal training
from taking a look at the
neighborhood training,
the prison training and implementing them
into one and then taking them on
and looking at them and
making them work for me.
So I had to mold them a scope to it
to something that fit me,
that having me being able to navigate
on the streets as a free man.
So being on the streets,
I'll police myself.
I know how to do that.
I know to make sure I stay out of trouble,
make sure not to stay
out of harm's way, man.
I don't put myself in a
position and speaking truthfully
to you all bullshit aside,
I did 19 trips to prison.
And in that time I had
to deal with the police.
Don't those 19 different occasions.
They never beat me up.
They never hurt me.
They never did no racial slurs.
I never been shot.
So when it really comes to me
identify with somebody
that's Poly gotten beaten up
or been recently slurred
or whatever comes with the territory.
We're dealing with some of those bad seeds
my bad, bad apples, then I can sympathize.
But I can't empathize because
bad has never happened
to me in all those 19 times
that I had to interact
with those dudes, man,
you know, or should I say
for them coming to my rescue in a real way
'cause sometimes I was begging pray
for them to come and
rescue me, man, for me
and the bullshit that I was
dealing with, man within myself
or some shit that I had
created that I couldn't handle.
And I had to get up out of
their exit stage left PO.
Now he's seeing me.
No you don't.
I wasn't bullshitting when it
gets too hot in the kitchen
I know where to go.
I know how to escape,
but for the life of me
I never thought that my interactions
with the police would cause me any harm.
You know, I'd I never
imagined never fathomed that.
Even when all this stuff is going
on around me, Bob, I'm
hearing about this happening
and that taking place in this
state and over here, you know
like I said, that self-deception,
that should just sat
and me like, Oh, well, shit it ain't me.
It ain't nobody in my family.
So I can live with that.
And I could a long time, as
long as it didn't hit home.
During those 19 times, I had to see them,
always flick that they're a mess.
You guys are here to protect,
to serve their community
to which I live in, and you
guys are civil servants.
So that means you're at my Beck and call.
So when it comes to
interacting a dealer with me
I'm supposed to feel comfortable.
I'm supposed to feel this
or that kind of certain
way when you're around.
But even as a youngster, as a teenager
I remember being young
and have been just what my
friends remember playing
in the streets, playing
tag, we're playing football
in a pass by and I've got
this messed up feeling
in my spirit and my soul and my stomach.
I got this funny feeling and
it wasn't a good feeling.
And I said, I'm wondering
what that comes from
because I never had any negative
dealings with the police.
But every time I would see them,
I would get this funny feeling in my soul.
And I remember they would
come by and we'd be hanging
out on the block as teenagers
and jump out the car
and wanna be nosy and ask
questions and all that bullshit.
And my palms historic against weed.
Then I feel this uncomfortable
feeling and I'm like,
damn, where is this coming from?
And I'd had no way to deal meant
that was part of the real me,
not the self-deception,
not the self-hatred
but that real feeling that
was going over with them
even though nothing bad ever happened.
It was that identification
to all the other people
that that bullshit had happened to.
That's what that feeling was
letting me know, warning,
warning, warning.
It could be your ass.
So it's time to be on top of your game.
It's time to be on.
You've got to come with
your, a game with them.
'Cause you could be next, I can be next.
And that's more so true
now than at any point
in place in time of my life.
I'm 53 years old and up is
more being more magnified, man.
As I get past these little personal things
these little personal character traits
or these personal wrong
how can I say, I want to overcome
personal character defect,
personal flaw with the
self-deception and the self-hate.
And once I make it to the other side
my eyes opened to
something new is revealed
to me and was been revealed to me as men.
I'm not exempt from some bad
happening to me by the hand.
So the police, you know, I'm not special.
I'm not unique in a better,
not let my guards now
for one second, I better
keep on what my a game.
So every time I see them
if my palms get swayed
and let them get sweaty,
don't stop 'em getting sweaty.
Don't let me start
getting that nervousness.
Don't let me start feeling
that feeling deep in the pit
of my mother fucking stomach
that means to beat it
and I need to sustain it here.
'Cause that keeps me aware
of what's really going on
because the blinders is off.
Should I got to see it for what it is?
That could be me.
I'm George, I'm Eman Tillman,
Malcolm X, Dr. Martin Luther King, Jr.
Shit I'm that mother
fucker that played in world
as would the boy I was
Swole Vin Rose, that's me.
I'll let them to do is put myself
in his shoes and it's easy today.
It's not hard because
when I'm looking at mirror
guess who's looking back at me
each and every one at Elm, from Rosa Parks
Harriet Tubman,
Nat Turner, they live within me.
They live within my spirit.
They guide me.
They pray for me.
They work with me.
They abide in me.
Because if I wouldn't even notice
unless I read up on it
I had to read the books and
see the movies to get that.
They get that part of
me, on the port, in him
every last one of them.
Cause I'm free.
I'm not slave to a motherfucking thing.
The only way it can be
in the bullshit that I put to myself.
That's the only way I'll ever be a slave
to any thing is some shit that I create.
That's the only way I'll be a cripple.
I've got to do it to myself.
The police can't even do to me
what I did to myself over the
years, then with that drinking
and some drugs fucked me up
and I fed it would be scored.
Need to write a book about that
but all aside, it does matter.
Black lives matter, all lives matter
because today my life matters.
My life means something to me.
Come to think about it is
back when I was growing up
in a neighborhood and
when somebody got shot
or somebody got stabbed or whatever
the reason somebody came
through the police came through
and shot up the house and
did this and wolf some shit
it wasn't a marching over
there in the name of the person
or the name of the house or
whoever was at that time.
And that hasn't changed.
Now you gotta be a lot of people talking
about the black on black crime
black on black this, the black
on black that, that's true
but you got that in every race,
but the only things they show on TV
is the black on blacks
that trustees that we
commit against ourselves man
but it's one thing that
bothers me about that.
I remember when I first came
home from prison, I was gone
from 2011 to 2017 and I
went to my mom's house, man.
And I remember walking down the street
and there were some railroad tracks, man
but that was the shortcut to get
to the train to the green line.
And instead of walking
to the corner and going
up to Vermont and just
walking to the train
or I take the shortcut
down the side street
go past the railroad tracks
till I get to the green line.
And I remember seeing
some candles, a mixture
of cross of some flowers
and all that bullshit.
And I'm like, I'm wondering what happened.
So I'll get back to the house
and she run it down to me.
Oh, yesterday somebody
came through and killed
so-and-so down on it.
Yeah, I saw a little makeshift.
Yeah, that's what it happened.
And it was like maybe
once every other week, man
I would see a makeshift
candle man and makeshift cross
with the candles and all
that bullshit on the side
of the different parts
of the railroad tracks.
And either the police then did it
or it was just somebody that
just happened to get caught
up at the wrong place at the wrong time.
But I'm seeing nobody marching for them.
I was caught up in that self-deception.
It wouldn't even dawned on me where he at
who was that person, who was
that boy, who was that girl?
Who was that woman?
Who was that man?
Because I'm walking the
same mother fuckin' trill.
I'm walking the same path.
I mean, I'm walking the same rail.
So I'm no exempt from somebody rolled up
on me pushing up on me.
I'll go the same way and it's dangerous.
Moms used to tell me,
man, go the long way.
Hell no, I'm not going a long
way because it's the long way.
I'll take my chances on
the danger or the shortcut.
You know, it's just
the way I'm wired, man.
Ain't that some shit?
Because I don't wanna
walk the long way around.
I'm going to take my
chances on getting shot
or some shit like that.
It's a way to adjust
to where the chips fall
let them fall or they lay, sheared.
So to blind is alpha test self-deception.
So I wonder when I'd be walking
by those makes your crosses
into candles in a little teddy
bear, who was that child?
Who was that son?
Who was that brother?
Who was that sister?
Who was that man?
Who was that woman?
I know it ain't no family.
I know we're not related,
but God, what did he add?
What a March is that?
Would it pick a size
and all that bullshit,
the crowds and all that.
What a microphone was that
at worst I will let that
bullshit sing kumbaya.
He's at the George Floyd's
and all that bullshit
with his what is hell of a speech
written as Al sharpton,
he gave a hell of a little
testimony at George's services.
But I never seen that mother
fuckin' in the neighborhood.
I ain't never seen him over there
by the railroad tracks man.
And since I've been men,
I was with my mom a year and a half man.
And I didn't see seven
different makeshift crosses
and candles man doing a year
and a half that's seven lives
in a year and a half man
that I got to pay tribute
to that I got to pay witness
to every time I walked
to the train, I have to
pass by, take a pause
for the calls and looked
at it and see the picture
whoever the individual was, I
think going above my business.
Thank you God, thank God it ain't me.
But I had time and to take that pause
for the cause and that's
what made the difference.
That's what penetrative my insensitive ass
you know me not wanting to know,
me not giving a fuck, me
not caring, that was enough.
So now when they talk
about Black Lives Matter
for the last one, whatever,
the last thing that went
on over here with the
brother, George, George bluff
or whatever his name
is, man, I didn't March.
Hail no, I didn't feel like it.
You know, but I appreciate
all the people that did
I wanted to so bad, but at the times
where I was gonna do it
it was too much going on at the time, man.
So I couldn't, but I wanted to.
And the cool thing about it
is man, I had that empathy.
So I'll put myself in
those protesters shoes.
I put myself in his people's shoes,
his family member's shoes.
Now I saw the tribute they gave him
and the ceremony and
all that kind of stuff.
And it was beautiful, man.
I love the brothers and
sisters that showed up.
I love the singers.
I love everybody that contributed
and all that kind of stuff,
but I need to see down
what the average mother fuckin' Jos.
I need to see those whose
name was in the neighborhood.
I need to see them sing
and dance and Sheldon and
all, let that bullshit too.
'Cause there's too many that are dying.
And I don't see enough mother fuckers
in the neighborhood marching.
I don't see them picketing
and all that bullshit.
I don't see what they makeshifts
stands and all that kind
of bullshit and got the music going
and got the choir and
all that other stuff.
Now you just see a makeshift
mother fuckin' cross
with the candles and a
picture of this person.
That's the end, that's all
the recognition you get.
They were probably blind guy,
you've got the whole world
in a mother fuckin' upper.
Everybody's doing some for Kobe
and I'll take nothing away from Kobe.
I love Kobe.
I was in a deep depression for three days
behind his ass and his
daughter getting dying.
She'd kill me, hurt me to the core.
The whole world was affected by it.
Then you had this girl
in my building complex.
She tripped down the stairs
and broke her mother fuckin' neck.
All I have was a little picture of her.
No makeshift cross, no shrine, no nothing.
Just a picture and a couple roses.
And let me tell you the
coldest part of that situation.
She had broke her neck, walking
down the stairs two days
prior to Kobe Bryant and his
daughter to getting killed
in that helicopter crash.
You know what?
Kobe Bryant took proceedings
of her little thing
that happened in my building.
And let me share that's Colt
that I've never witnessed
in my mother fuckin' life.
As I'm coming out, my
apartment going down the stairs
I see her family coming down,
getting ready to exit the building.
You got the mama, you got the
sister, you got the brother
and you got a little brother
and they're all carrying
plastic trash bags,
I guess that was all her
possession in trash bags.
And I knew it was her family
by the looks on their faces.
I know what was looked
at the mama's how to look
at her mother, her parents,
like she couldn't believe it.
Like my damn, my baby.
I didn't see nobody, I didn't
see no orchestra there.
I didn't see no green
committee like they do.
What, Walmart and Target
has somebody greets you
when you walk in a store?
Honestly, no welcome to committee.
I had seen her entire
broken down, family, leaving
all her stuff in trash bags,
all her worldly possessions.
I wonder what it was
like when he was going
through her little apartment
and getting a hold of all
her personal effects, man.
Ooh, I wouldn't want to
be in them shoes, man.
But I had to place myself in
them shoes, I had to be there.
So thank God, I got to see that
because doing a whole thing
with Kobe Bryant and his
daughter, I've got the witness.
I got the see that.
I got the see that part, her.
I got to see who loved her,
who cared enough about her.
That's deep.
That meant more to me
than the Kobe thing, man.
'Cause somebody showed up for
her and ain't bring no band.
I didn't bring no special speeches
and no got to do to talk
me for none of that.
They didn't need no
intermediates, no translations
none of that stuff.
They didn't come with the marching band.
They didn't come with the harmony singers.
They came quietly and got her stuff
and left the same way they came invisible.
I was so shook up.
I didn't even pay homage, man.
I couldn't even say nothing
as bad as want to say some
of my condolences to
the mom and all of them.
It shook me up so bad.
Just seeing them in that procession
leaving it just ah, just, Oh
my God, it just, it floored me.
And I've got, I'm just
watching in slow motion.
As they're walking out someone solely
with her personal stuffs in trash bags.
And he exited the building and I said,
I'll never see him again.
And I'll never see her again.
And I'd even deal with her
on a regular basis to see her
in passing, but a beautiful
kids spirit, beautiful woman.
So that was the turning point for me
when it happened in my
building with that woman.
So until I see people protesting
and marching for the
ones that are not famous,
that's not rich, that didn't
die by the hands of the police
if you can't march for them
then why you're marching
for the ones that's going to
bring you some exposure, man
because it's a lot of
us dying, right, left
that don't have that kind of
exposure that, but we need it.
Know there's a lot of mamas.
There's a lot of daddies.
There's a lot of grandmas
in the neighborhood,
scared to death.
I just came from visiting my
mother just yesterday, man.
And every time she talk about man
I'll walk around the corner.
I walked down the streets,
you know, I'll be like, God
watch over this one, man.
She's all I got.
Watch over this one, please.
I would hate to see something bad happened
to her men on a humbug men
on a fluke man, happenstance.
You know that shit did do
something to me, you know?
Cause I love my mama, I'm a mamas boy
but she'd get up and she'd get around me
and like she supposed to
and I ain't mad at her,
but that's the danger of the street
and that's the danger of corner
by the railroad tracks are man.
It ain't changed.
She don't even go that way.
I still do.
Ain't that some shit?
I'm not playing with fire.
I'm not playing with the gang.
That's my choice.
I've been making bad
choices, decisions in my life
on almost every mother fuckin'
thing that I've experienced
in my life too many.
So I'm learning how to
make the right choices
and decisions today.
I'm not perfect.
I got a long way to grow in certain areas
but I'm not going to give up
the good fight for what's right.
And mama (indistinct) doing a protest
for any injustice men,
no matter who it is.
'Cause not just Black Lives Matter
which is important, but
it's like all lives matter.
But some people just
don't see the importance
of the black life.
Some people just don't
get it that black man
and the black women were important.
Were worthy, were
somebody, were some special
if not to your mother fuckin
ass to somebody love us enough.
Somebody care enough about us.
You ain't never met him.
You probably never will see them.
So whoever got them, civil servant jobs
as the police and the Sheriff's
and all that bullshit who
don't have that temperament.
then maybe you need to check
your mother fuckin training.
And if it's the technique,
if you saw one of your partners
or another officer have somebody
need a choke hold or a hat
they put her in the neck
and you saw somebody die.
Now you wouldn't know going and going
into the next person that you might come
across that you wouldn't try it as.
Cause you know what don't work.
So if you still try some
shit that you saw somebody
who choose to kill
somebody, then fuck you!
You know you were wrong.
'Cause you know what it did.
I'm an ex cracks.
I'm an ex crack smoker.
So if I'm walking down
the street 900 a month
I can crack cos man.
And I'll know they up
in they're willing to deal with the smoke.
(indistinct)
I'm not gonna go up in the air
'cause I know I've got coming.
I know how bad I've got.
I know how I bad I am.
So when I tilt my ass I don't give a fuck.
If he got the pied Piper
leading 1,000 people
in and out there all day
I'm not going to jump in line with them.
Cause I already know what I
got coming already know better.
Cause I know it's nothing good.
It's all bad.
So to all the police officers
if you're not a civil
servant, if you're not
up for the job and please man
find something else to do.
And if you've got man,
I'm sure some which meant
even doing my training days
in the neighborhood men
it was always two absolutes for me.
And it was a racist, a racist society
in a system that was set up,
especially when I got to
the criminal justice system
I got to see how the
system was set up, man
because a lot of people that go in
and out of the criminal justice
systems are people of color
black men, a lot of black men I saw in,
because all of my 19 trips to prison
and all those holding sales,
all those holding tanks,
the majority of it is black.
I'm like 85% black got a few Hispanics
and you got a few white sprinkling in
just to add the flavor to it.
And I saw the majority of us
we didn't have attorneys,
personal attorneys.
We couldn't afford private
attorneys to represent us.
So we had to get the public defenders
and they didn't give a fuck.
I didn't find out this
until the 15 trip to prison
that they really didn't care.
We're just a number, man.
You know what you got they
making deals with the DA,
Hey man I'm gonna get you
these three right here,
I'll let this mother fucker right here go.
He got a petty theft this
is 20th time let him go.
He just can't get it right.
But he will sooner or later.
I mean that's how they do this
trade and we're human beings.
We're human beings.
So now at 53 years old I'm more mindful
I'll police myself more and
I'm more or less scared, man.
When I've run across the police
even though nothing is
bad, never happened to me.
God damn, but I'm not exempt.
That's why it is I'm
more scared than ever.
I'm more fearful now
because I don't want
to be the next George,
I don't wanna be the
next one, George Floyd,
Elma Tillman, Malcolm X.
I don't give a fuck who it is.
It ain't even got to be no,
I just don't wanna be the next one.
I don't wanna be the next statistic
because I can be and it's real easy.
So I'll bring my A game.
And if I don't have my A
game on during the beginning
of the day, I'll keep my ass at home.
I won't even go nowhere if I'm not going
to represent to the top of my game
cause I don't need to be out there
bullshitting, shucking and jiving
in a mother fuckin' way.
'Cause as soon as I get my ass in my way
that's when all hell breaks loose, man.
And it's always been like
that and it always will.
So I'm not out here
on the streets just to be out
here just to find something
to get into a and if any, none to get into
I don't get into nothing.
If there's nothing to
do, I don't do nothing.
I stay put, I don't need, I'm not looking
for trouble today because
it's too easy to find
in as hard as hell to get out of.
It's not easy.
Does all lives matter?
Yes they do absolutely no
doubt but most importantly,
for those who don't
believe who don't think so
Black Lives Matter too.
It starts with me and it ends with me
but I'mma say it like this.
It starts with us and it ends with us all.
Now during the time where
I had that self-hatred
I didn't give a fuck about
no Black Life Matter.
'Cause I couldn't stand my black ass.
It took me a long time
to come to the other side
of that bullshit that right there
with the self-hatred, by my upbringing
and all the that bullshit
that went on in my life
and all my experiences leading
up to me being a teenager,
leading up to being a
young adult into manhood.
By the time I got to
manhood, I was so disgusted
with me and my race and all that bullshit
and I hated being black because I was poor
and I was black and I was in
real trouble at an early age.
And I saw the mother fuckin' writings
on the wall when around
seven to eight years old
I saw what I was destined for.
I wasn't bullshitting when I said,
I mean it from the bottom
of my mother fuckin' heart.
I knew where I was headed.
And it was in that neck has stopped me
from getting near and I've
got there on the fast track.
If I didn't get past that self-deception
and that self-hatred then black lives
wouldn't matter I'd be in
a pit talking right now
because it wouldn't mean a
mother fuckin' thing to me.
But since I've got passing into
the decided means the world
to me, because I'm speaking for myself too
as a black male living in
Los Angeles, California.
I got to represent me.
I got to stand up for me.
I Always say that I'm all I got,
I got to be there for
me and take care of me
you're mother fuckin' right,
I got to take care of me.
That's why I'm up here talking for me
'cause it matters today.
I matter, I mean its real to me today.
And if somebody means the world to me
I've got a mama that love me.
I got a sister, I got
siblings, I got nieces
I've got nephews, they
love their uncle Eric.
Now the average Joe might say
out, man, fuck this dude, man.
I ain't tripping over
Hill and that's cool, man.
That's your prerogative.
It's your thing, do what you wanna do.
I can't tell you to sock it too.
But I know for me, its support
that I reciprocate to
those who got that love
for being as genuine.
That's what keep me going.
That's what keep me on my thing.
You know, that's the kick me on my thing.
So whosever got that feeling
like it doesn't matter.
They don't care.
It ain't happened, it
ain't hit close to home.
That's all right, man.
But you always got to remember
try to put yourself in
somebody else's shoes,
because you came in
when it happened to you,
and nobody's show for y'all
mother fuckin' services
or nobody's show up to
speak anything good for you.
Then you're gonna know why.
I got a partner, that just
passed in an accident.
And it was hard for his family
to kinda get everything situated.
Had a real struggle with the finances
for the burial and all that kind of stuff.
We needed some help and
went on social media
to get some assistance.
And I was thinking about that.
So what I learn from that
experience with my partner is
if I don't put nothing out there
then I can't get nothing on the return.
So if I'm not doing anything,
if I'm not suiting up
and showing up, if I'm
out there protesting
for the injustices, if
I'm not out there trying
to do my part then if
something happened to me,
or somebody in my family
I can't expect nobody
to suit up and show up.
I can't expect nobody to make no donations
and all that kind of stuff.
I can't expect that
because I didn't do it.
What comes around, goes around.
And I believe that wholeheartedly.
So it's about time I
got my black ass in line
and do what the fuck I'm
supposed to do when I stand up.
Like everybody else is standing up
for any injustice anywhere,
anytime that goes on
they probably won't even feel like it.
But they doing it.
It was more other races this time
for George Brown than
any anybody I've seen
excuse me, George Floyd,
from anybody I've seen
in Los Angeles, California downtown LA.
I'm being at the bus
stop doing a protest man.
And it was all these junk
key is walking up and back up
down the street, what they size
and all that kind of stuff.
We're tired.
And I'm like, Oh my God.
I'm like, thank you God for
them because I can't do it.
Cause I was tired too.
And I just didn't feel
like to be honest with you.
'Cause I had so much other
stuff going on at the time
but they took the time off to do it.
And that's my only regret.
I had time I'll have to do was make it.
So some shit ever
happened to me back then.
I'll hope nobody don't
say that in my behalf.
Oh, I'll feel for our
young Eric (indistinct)
biggie, uncle E, whatever the fuck.
I just ain't got the time, man.
Some real important came up, man.
I just can't be there for
the brother like I want to
that hurt my family,
especially for the few
friends that I have.
And if this is some shit like that
I roll over my muffin grave
and tried to get their ass.
So I have to be mindful what I put
out there and I have to do my part
and it's real important, man.
That actions speak louder than words.
So while I'm sitting up here
gave me the smile fucking,
I was gonna say song and dance
but it's not that I'm
not give you my testimony
on being a black man in Los Angeles.
And it is important that
actions follow these words
that I'm spitting, man.
I could have kept my at home
and have somebody else sit
up here and tell you this
or shared this information
with (indistinct) joy
but Black Lives Matter.
Please, don't get it twisted.
Thank you.